buddy hello hello oh my god new background well technically
it's old background we've had this back this background was
done for a while now and i just i was finally not lazy i
just wanted to show you guys this new background i'm at your
desk and be like did you do your homework did you did you do
mrs mrs stacy's homework i get a copy off of it real quick
uh No, no chat.
It's because that was the one thing I forgot to put on.
I forgot to put the chat up.
I did almost everything.
All right.
Also, I want to, oh my god, if you...
Okay, I have Club Penguin open up right now.
And a penguin literally was like, if you love Jesus, like my
igloo.
And then he got snapped.
He got snapped because you're not um in club I saw him
disappear in front of my eyes I saw him he got snapped out
of existence so our goal is to not get banned on club
penguin today uh anyway uh okay anyway uh uh what was I
gonna say oh yeah um I've been have still been having uh he
got raptured he had jesus heard you and he got raptured
anyway so uh i still i'm still having really bad sleep at
the moment um i slept at okay so long long story short um i
slept at a.m.
today and i woke up four um i it was uh when oh my gosh you
can tell that my you can tell how you can tell that i slept
at fucking 8 a.m right now of how my brain is processing
stuff uh
um yeah so it's we're not improving at all we're in fact we
are sleeping later and later because yesterday it was like i
think it was like five or like six a.m now it's eight a.m um
and And then the day before yesterday, it was like, I think
it was also a bit earlier, but now it's getting worse.
Because like, I was tossing and turning for like three hours
in bed.
So I got up at around like 5 a.m.
because I was just like, I'm not falling asleep.
I can't fall asleep.
So I've just been like, you know, I've been in bed.
In the bed, too.
I've been trying to sleep.
I was in the bed until 5 in the morning.
I was like, it's not going to work.
And I told my manager, I was just like, you know what?
I'm just going to stay up.
the club penguin stream and then um and then just tank it
just take it just go to the club penguin stream sleep
deprived up at least i'll be able to sleep the next day and
then and then 8 a.m rose up and i was like i can't do that i
can't do that i can't do this like
i can't i can't pull an all-nighter i can't do that i was
like i'm i'm tired now i'm tired now
like tapped out at 8.
I was just like, I survived three more hours after proposing
that idea.
You know, I was like, 5 a.m.
I was like, I think I could do this.
Like, I think it was like the second win or some shit.
I was just like, I could do it.
I, I think I could stay up till like, I don't know, till
like 10 p.m.
or some shit.
I think I could do it.
And then 8 a.m.
Rose, I was like, I can't.
I'm, I'm fucking, I'm out.
I'm, bye.
It's just too weak.
I can't.
My brain was like, that was a terrible idea.
I was like, you were right.
I should have, I should have done that.
Anyway, let's, alright, so, I'm going to be playing Club
Penguin today.
A lot of people were very surprised that Club Penguin still
exists.
It still technically exists.
It's always had a very dedicated fan community.
I think Disney shut it down, shut it down because even
before Disney bought it, it was like so fucking popular.
Like, it was everywhere.
I remember, I started the Club Penguin craze at my school
because, uh, um, because uh uh we had like these school
computers i'll get on it i'll be i'll be on club penguin and
people like all this because there's only three computers
there's three shared computers at the classroom during like
and we were all like huddled up like whoever gets to it
first gets to like you know uh use it for recess and then um
i when i was on it i would get on club i i don't know how i
just oh i think i discovered club penguin from neopets uh
people on neopets were talking about club penguin.
I was like, what's club penguin?
And then they poured unfortunate abbreviation of letters now
for it.
But anyway, and then I remember my classmates, they would
huddle around me and be like, oh my god, what is that?
I was like, that's club penguin.
It's the newest, it's the newest game that everybody's crazy
about.
And oh, and then I got everyone in class obsessed with
Everyone would just be on Club Penguin And there was this
one fucker who was like Yeah, my parents let me buy a
subscription And not because he would be like dripped out
And be like, yeah, look at this Look at this puff line buy
Yeah, I'm look at this Look at all these clothes I have
Because the rest of us were free to play And this fucker
would just be like Like flexing his subscription Do I was
like, yeah, my parents bought a free I mean, I'm subscribed
And we were all just peasants who were just free to play.
So there's always that one guy, a daddy's credit card, who
gets to be paid to win and gets to have the cool puffles and
the fucking cool clothes that they can wear for his penguin.
Like all the rest of us were naked.
And he gets to wear shirts.
So paid to Penguin.
Yeah, that guy.
That fucker.
His sister was so nice, though.
His sister was so nice.
But oh, that guy was a fucking ass.
That guy.
He was such a fucking asshole.
Yeah, I was a proud free to Penguin.
At Club Penguin.
Anyway.
um i like it was a really popular game it was at a really
dedicated community i am playing on club penguin journey uh
there are several websites all right let's get right into it
let's get right into club penguin so there are several uh
also i don't know if it's too loud this music is so annoying
i will say that like the bgm i've been listening to this bgm
for like the past 10 minutes.
I had to actually mute it for myself.
Anyway.
Anyway, so there are several Club Penguin websites that like
several fan communities have rebuilt Club Penguin.
Oh, is it muted for you too?
No, it's not.
I can see it playing on my side.
Oh, it's just how I will turn it up a little bit so you guys
can enjoy the music a little bit more.
Um, don't so yeah but you don't know which one's me yeah you
don't know i've you don't know i'm in that pile right now
you don't know which one's me which one is my penguin um so
i am there are several ones i looked up because i was like
which one which one do i which one do i go on and apparently
this one has the uh oh it's a very quiet oh you guys don't
want it any louder it's actually annoying this music is
actually it loops it never stops looping by the way it it
never so it just unlike others this one never stops looping
um uh unlike my intro yeah that's right you don't know which
one you're throwing that snowball to that's right i could be
any one of those penguins
I was as I was saying are you just sending random friend
requests until it hits until it hits the penguin you think I
am like because okay for those who don't know for those who
don't know uh when you club penguin journey they uh we did
and hit war for those who don't know so my name is just a
random numbers so you can see like the p859 p80 because they
manually that apparently you don't get your name approved
until three weeks minimum um so because the the staff team
manually reviews each username it isn't automate automated
at all so they can make this like uh family friendly so this
is like a place for kids you know because it is a fucking
game for children
that's right I could be the green penguin you don't know
what color penguin I am I could be any one of those penguins
so you know I thought like all create a penguin in advance
um and I'll just create a uh a random penguin in advance so
that maybe my name will show up but then I read up it was
like two to three weeks and I was like all right that that's
not Yeah, that's not happening.
You think you're the yellow one?
I could be that blue one right there.
You don't know that.
I could be that pink one.
I could be that green one dancing in the corner.
That could be me.
You know, I think it might not be yellow.
Which penguin am I?
Oh my God, there's so many penguins now.
There's so many.
Um, but the great thing about like fan community, the blue
one is already got, yeah, yeah, but there's another blue
one.
I could be that orange one right there, the orange penguin
right there.
Um, so not the green yellow one with the big circle.
Oh, wait, there's a circle around me.
Oh, that's awkward.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, shit.
Maybe if I...
Okay, okay, I didn't realize there was a circle around me.
I, I am, which penguin am I now?
Which,
it could be any one of them.
It could, that's right, which penguin am I now?
I didn't notice there was a, I didn't realize it was a
circle around me, I thought it was so, I thought I was so
clever, quick, quick, quick, hide on top of me, quick, all
the other penguins hide on top of me, um, can't unsee the
circle now, all right, anyway, what was I talking about,
okay, so, um, apparently, uh, because it has such a, that's
right, Now you see me.
Now you don't.
You're the one just rotated and be back to resting.
Thank you for the super chat.
Guys, you gotta be careful though.
Apparently the chat system is very, I think, moderated.
So you get one warning and then you're out, basically.
I think it's one warning and then you're out because I saw a
good mythical morning video about it.
It just showed him I recommend it.
I was like, oh, I'm playing Club Penguin soon.
We're playing, oh, and they're playing Club Penguin too.
And then literally he was like, I don't remember what he
typed.
I think he was like, yeah, he was like, he was like, he was
like, he found a random fan.
They found a random fan in Club Penguin.
And then he was like, what do you think about Good Mythical
Morning to the fan?
She was like, I don't like them.
And they're like, why?
They're like, oh, I don't like them.
I think they're a bit weird.
And then they're like, oh, why?
And then the kid was like, oh, because they touched me
weird.
And then, you know, in front of the Good Mythical Morning
team and the staff and everybody was like, what?
They're like, yeah, I met them.
I like saw them in real life once and they're like oh how
was it's like well they sort of touched me and weird and
they're like and then everyone's the mythical boarding guys
were just like they're just like you know that's like yeah
and then and they're like they're like where like they were
like they typed up where did they touch you and then they
got banned they got a warning so they We're allowed to talk
to other penguins anymore They asked like where did they
touch you and then they got they got like they got kicked
off the like the server They so you got we have to be very
careful We're very careful with what do we say Very valid
what because they're like in shock they're like what do you
mean They're like we're on the teddy bear like
I was like, I'm sure, I was just like, what?
And then the staff obviously were filming this.
They're like, oh my God, like this is all happening right
now.
It was fucking crazy.
So I know the chat, I mean, I literally saw if you like
Jesus, like my alien.
I saw him got snapped by Thanos.
because it's so I was just like oh my god like so I know the
chat moderation is very strict because obviously there are
kids on this platform it is one of the fewer kid friendly
websites that children can use um which is great but yeah
this was like I didn't ask one my issue about the uh current
generation of online like communities and online gaming for
children uh because not a lot of them that are like clearly
like catered towards kids you know um there's not a lot of
them that do that anymore and like this is a fan community
as well as because you know disney disney closed down club
penguin and this is like one of few fan communities um that
resurrected um the platform and everything and it still gets
uh updates it still get you can see like a lot of fucking
shit that i was like i don't remember this from club penguin
like you know there's this guy fucking lifting the other
penguin down.
He's like, yippee guy, yeah.
And there's a DJ penguin.
I don't fucking know what the fuck Peng Peng is.
Like, ah, is that a crab?
I don't know.
There's a goddamn snail.
And then, oh, yes.
And then there's a hipster right here.
That guy's too cool for us.
Get don't keep bad from Club Penguin.
So, but thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank.
I feel like a lot of websites nowadays are not very
kid-friendly.
Even though they're supposed to be, like, geared towards
children um but like you know these safety measures aren't
there like uh so um so I feel like that you know it's really
nice to see that this uh this website is trying really hard
to like make sure it's a very safe space for kids um and
then there's me just fucking coming in and be like because I
I'm not getting I got nostalgia baited okay I'm it's not
because I'm like a child I'm just, I have lots of nostalgia.
I have a lot of nostalgia memories from playing Club
Penguin.
I would always, like, hang out at the restaurant
role-playing as a waiter or playing the sled races or doing
that bean game at the coffee shop.
I don't remember what it's called.
But I always loved hanging out and I always be like, who
wants to be my, who wants to be my friend?
does anyone want to be my friend um um so yeah let's go
explore around and play i want to do i don't know i don't
know which one i want to do first i want you know let's go
visit let's go visit the the dance club and go hit the dance
floor um let's see
go.
All right, see, now you know my name.
Let's go dance.
Oh my god, this is memory right there.
I'd be like, let's go guys.
Let's go.
Yeah!
Woo!
Oh my god, I earned a stats new.
I'd never seen that one before.
What was this?
Oh my god, new message.
Awesome outfit.
Thank you.
I'm naked.
I...
Dance!
I'm trying to, like, not get banned right now.
Oh, my God.
If we're all yellow, no one can...
No one will know which is the right penguin.
Which is the dokey penguin.
That's one warning.
I'm just saying dance.
That's all I'm saying.
Everyone.
Yellow.
Oh my god.
All the penguins.
Be yellow and huddle on top of me.
They'll never know which is the real dokey breed.
Hide my circle.
Everyone now.
Hide the circle.
Circle.
But I can't turn you.
I'm gonna buy a yellow bird.
Oh my gosh.
There we go.
Which one's me?
Which dokey could it be?
I don't know.
Which one?
I could be anyone.
of those penguins right there okay that's new that's an
inflatable penguin i also love playing the what was it the
the ship one oh my god look at that now you don't know which
penguin is me
surely there's no circle around me where is it you can't see
it there's I don't think you can see the circle no more
We're all dance Dance everyone Dance A platypus Perry the
platypus Look at that Hiding in plain sight We're all
dancing now Yeah they can't pat in me Oh they can't And find
me.
I didn't do nothing wrong.
I'm just dancing.
A penguin.
Doki the penguin.
A yellow penguin.
Look at that.
If we're all yellow.
Then we can all be Doki.
I am Doki bird.
No, I am Doki bird.
look at that a perfect disguise no one will ever know what
oh I remember thin ice okay I would be here and I would like
sit down no I'd be like I would like role-play in here all
right would you like to put yes please this is new I haven't
seen this before melt ice on your way through each maze once
the ice is melted.
Use arrow keys.
Oh, wait, I don't have arrow keys.
Oh, it's just that.
Okay, I can play it.
This game is easy.
Look at that.
Oh, my.
It's like a game for children.
I pressed...
Oh, wait, no, I actually have to...
I never played this.
I never seen this before in Club Penguin.
Bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump.
God, I'm so fucking smart.
Look at that.
No hesitation.
Okay.
I actually pressed...
Okay, look at that.
No hesitation at all.
Okay, we don't need that.
We don't need that either.
We don't need that, guys.
Oh, shit.
I have a wooden keyboard, okay?
I pressed stuff really, really fast.
It's a game for adults.
The tests are critical.
Oh, shit.
It's fine.
Look at that.
I told you.
It's fine.
Look at that.
See?
nothing to worry about we don't need that we don't need that
either we don't need either of those all right let's just
let's go die now oh no i can't leave i oh i can leave okay
i'll just leave yeah i got a coin bag look at me go i'm so
good at video games all right what the fuck welcome to
brazil Brazil!
Brazil!
Yeah!
Oh my god.
I went to Brazil!
I can't.
Come to Brazil.
Oh my god, we did it.
It threw a club penguin.
um i never expected you to run we did it guys we finally
came to brazil all it took was club penguin oh my god wait
the floor is yellow oh my god okay but but like who's
actually here from brazil like are all these penguins really
from brazil how did they do that wait i want to sign up for
dance contest i think i had those moves what's this yo
welcome to the nightclub i'm cadence they also know as dj k
dance i'm wait i want dance start the music that's right
let's do starting up there you go your song and we'll begin
about a minute okay so do i have to wait how do i do this
okay your song is and will the song is to practice it in
single play i'm gonna go in live you're if we're up for the
next your song is and we'll begin in about a minute oh okay
all right who am i who am i fighting it's ddr isn't it all
right means more arrows okay i don't really have arrow keys
on this keyboard i have to press like a function key to
access my arrow keys here i have a 60 keyboard all right 38
guys it's on easy mode how hard can it be it's on easy mode
on a kid in a kid's game might i add so
it can't be that difficult it's like it's a gamer keyboard
gamer keyboards tend to be like smaller just for like just
to fit like the desk like the desk and stuff it's just more
efficient when you're playing like FPS and stuff like that
because you don't need arrow keys when you're playing FPS
games so that's why they take it away oh holy shit this is
so slow wait maybe this is because it's easy that's right
not last though oh shit okay all right great
oh my god look at that i'm crumping it i'm crumping it oh my
god i'm moon walking oh my god i have a 25 comma i bet you
don't have that
Bungie down!
Oh shit, that was close.
Who has 2,000?
We're playing the same game.
Oh my god, this song is so long.
It's just looping, but it's surprisingly a really long song.
Wait, I fucked up my combo?
I've hit every single note.
Bump, bada, bada, bada.
okay not last not last guys someone has zero points someone
d seed you're what yeah but we're are you one the best
tantrum she's ever seen pure win you want nine I need coins
to look, you're ready for something.
You know, you're right.
You're fucking right.
I want to see how well I did it.
B, look at that.
That's a pass.
I like a...
Oh, I can get a different sign.
Okay.
I'll take hard, please.
I think I'm ready.
I think I'm fucking ready.
I couldn't tap anything on mobile.
And...
Well, and that's why you're last.
That's why you're last, girl.
Excuses.
You would find a way to tap on mobile.
All right, the Patrick's Jig.
Wow.
I like how the translation, wow, horse.
Wow, do you wrote, someone wrote, wow, dokey.
But the auto-Google translate was like, wow, horse.
I don't know, you guys can see it on the fucking chat
overlay.
I hate the auto-translation.
It's so inaccurate.
I don't even know what languages are they translating right
now.
Doki, horse.
Like, wow.
Doki is randomly translating.
randomly translating from horse
do you see dookini's I saw why did someone wrote stop it I
was like oh I'm sorry sir I'm sorry you know I'm sorry I
don't know I don't know maybe you just don't fucking like
horses and then you love her over it and it says dookini's
and it auto translates to stop it
I'm ready.
Alright, who are my...
Oh my god, I'm actually crumping in now.
Wait, this is by myself.
I don't want to play by myself.
Wait, get me out of here.
Oh my god, I'm so cool.
Wait, I gotta go back in.
Give me a sec, I fucked up.
I wanted a multiplayer.
Okay, multiplayer.
Hard.
oh do you not oh it's only one song expert it translates as
youtube shorts it means pants in korean more fall thank you
the super chat thank you thank you here we go i know 90 is
all right i'm ready your song is cool in the cold is that
the same song do they is multiplayer just the same song over
and over again is it a different song i've lost track this
expert level only real penguins can play this only like um
the professionals
oh my god that's right i can't believe copied club penguin
oh my god so shameless so fucking shameless that they would
steal from something from something like this yeah and you
don't even credit club penguin
oh my god it rotates what the fuck i don't think the kids
can do that i oh my god club penguin does not fuck around Oh
my god!
Okay, I might actually need a keyboard.
I don't think I can play.
Oh my god, oh my god, okay, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, there's lyrics?
Guys, I'm not bad.
I'm just, I have to...
Oh god.
Oh god, oh god, guys, guys, guys, pause, pause.
Pause.
I need my other keyboard.
Okay.
Okay guys, guys, I'm gonna grab my other keyboard.
I'm gonna, I'm actually gonna grab my other keyboard if I'm
doing this.
It's okay, I'm still not last though.
I can catch up.
Okay, I'm unplugging.
Where's the hole for this keyboard?
Okay, there we go.
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh, uh-oh.
last because someone dc'd oh my god
what what kid is doing this oh
Okay, the people who are lower, what's your excuse?
I'm a keeper.
Was it plugged for, like, for, like, at least 20 seconds?
Oh, my God.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, cool, cool, cool.
Oh,
when does the song end?
God, they do not play.
You did not play in Club Penguin, that's for sure.
Oh, my God, stop tripping.
Just dance.
Just dance, Doki.
Wait, look.
All I'm saying, I'm still not last.
My keyboard was literally not plugged.
did for at least 10 seconds for it was it was not played
what's your excuse
not well that was hey hey 99 coins is 99 coins Okay, that's
99 Buccaroonies
All right, we're leaving we're leaving.
Oh my god, what the fuck it Another game I used to love.
Oh wait, what's this?
I never heard this one Smoothies.
Yes, I would like to play smoothie smash, please.
I've never heard of this game before survival Oh
oh okay all right don't worry i know now wait why am i not
moving oh i am i i am using my arrow keys okay wait maybe my
keyboard isn't registering guys i think my keyboard wasn't
registering okay there you go there you go there you go one
life just gotta get all those coins what Okay, wait, I
understand now, guys.
I understand.
Guys, I understand now.
The horse?
Horse.
Do you see the horses in chat?
Easy.
see look at that first try boom oh my god i'm gonna get
bored soon of how good i am at this game give me a real
fucking challenge
oh shit wait they start moving now wait they start moving
now all right no they're bombs i'm pretty sure they're bombs
guys i don't think they would put one fucking berry one
fucking blueberry oh my god i missed it by okay that's it
that's fine all right so this is a game i would play a lot i
would challenge people i don't know how to play it anymore
where am i oh i'm i'll be your server today oh wait he's the
server never mind oh beans what is this oh i play this all
the time i love this game yeah I was really good this game
all I did was I was just stacking beans I was very good at
menial labor is that what's called menial oh you know what I
can just pick up more more beans manual labor sorry manual
man yeah okay that does not count that's all right manual I
remember it started with m oh wait that's a lot of beans now
that's a lot of beans guys that That's a lot of beans.
Guys, why do we have anvils in the bean?
Oh, God, no.
Guys, why do we have anvils in the bean truck?
Okay, that's fine.
The beans dying doesn't matter.
As long as I don't get hit by the anvils.
Wait, is fish good?
Fish not good.
Wait, I still...
Oh.
Oh, that's fine.
I can let a couple of...
Oh, oh.
Get dodged.
Oh, I don't know.
I'm a penguin.
I like fish.
How is I supposed to know fish is not good?
Oh.
I missed, like, the flash game aesthetic.
There's been a lot of cool flash games over the years.
We won't get that anymore because flash is dead.
Oh.
i know like adobe actually tried it like killed like the
successor what was it called adobe character animation or
whatever okay i'm pretty sure flower not good what oh my god
for that double there's no way it takes okay there is a
limit to how much i can carry i don't know i thought like
because of all the experiencing carrying beans i get better
at it my weight threshold?
Okay, I got okay, I gotta throw at the needle.
You gotta let some beans.
Okay, that's bullshit.
Where the fuck do I go?
I missed the good classics, though.
There's just something about flash games that just hit
right.
The simplicity.
Alright, area.
I think my co-worker hates me.
I'm not sure yet Alright I'm not very sure I can't be sure
though Like But I have a suspicion that he doesn't like me
Oh okay I saw one more left I saw one more left I thought
Club Penguin was shut down Um it has a very Uh big fan
community And they basically recreated the game And still
has like an community so they like basically recreate the
game and updated every like couple of months or every every
month or so like there's even like subscriptions and
everything oh shit nice congratulations i did it look at
that beat the game i beat the game i'm so good at club
penguin all right this is the game that would play a lot all
right fin fin okay he wasn't actually alive Someone
challenged me.
I forgot how to play this game.
But someone challenged me.
Which one's my side?
This is my side, right?
Okay.
This one.
And I get a free turn.
Go again.
Alright.
And then...
I just got this.
Alright.
That's right.
I'm a professional.
I'm a professional beiner.
I put those beans in that hole Okay Five
What Wait what does that mean?
I thought Oh my god what did I say?
I'm Canadian I just want to talk about Bees I just Bees
I'm Canadian I'm Canadian I didn't know
I just wanted I just wanted to talk about B
It's okay I'm winning though at least
I said me One two three Four five six Okay I'm getting the
beans I'm getting the beans i'm getting the beans guys let
me go damn another free turn i'm winning go again okay and
then more oh my god is that another is that another free
turn that's right that's another free turn wait how is my
score hot like not that hot
I just wanted to play with beans.
How did I capture?
It's Mikala!
Mekala!
That's right.
Another free turn.
Is that another free turn?
Damn.
There you go.
Mekala, I won.
I won, guys.
In the end, I won.
That's right.
I actually don't know how to play this game.
I just remember the free turn.
Okay.
The last stone is dropping an empty hole on the end.
the player they capture all oh that's right that's right i'm
a professional she came back to the
game hey you're in a super chat all right bam free turn damn
right free turn oh i should have kept that fuck okay Um,
I'll move this.
Oh, wait, he's figuring it out.
Okay, six.
Return.
Go again.
Gonna put this here.
Oh, capture!
Give me your beans!
I'm beaning right now.
Okay, I'm gonna put...
Make sure there's that.
There's no way.
All right, there you go.
One here.
Go again.
I'm going to capture this bean.
Give me your beans.
How does he have 28?
I have more beans than him.
Give me your beans.
Wait, how does he have more beans than me?
Yeah.
Oh, I have more beans now.
That's right.
Free turn.
Give me that.
That's right.
I have more beans now.
Oh, no way you captured my beans.
Okay.
I'm just going to put them here so you can't capture my
beans.
And now I'll put this here.
And now I'll have two.
That's right.
I could go again.
One, two, three, four, five.
You can't capture these.
Three.
That's fine.
I don't care if he captures this.
I still win.
I have more beans on my side than you.
That's right.
matter what you do, you lose.
You might as well quit right now.
Come on.
Did I win?
I won.
I think I won.
That's a king rep.
I play this shit all the time.
I hang out here all day long.
Okay.
Boy.
I don't actually know what I'm doing, by the way.
get rid of these beans i don't really understand how we get
more points i just like to do the free i just like to do the
free turn shit
okay five oh another free turn damn right that's another
free turn for me oh let's see i should put these out of here
come on put that bean
I don't actually understand this game either.
Don't worry, guys.
I just like putting beans in the hole.
That's fucking right.
Oh my god, we're tied.
But guess who has unlimited free turns?
Oh, you made a fatal mistake, girl.
Is that another free turn?
I'm doing math right now.
I'm doing math.
All right.
There we go.
She might have 30 now, but don't worry, guys.
Watch this turn around.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I'm thinking right now, guys.
I'm analyzing the situation.
okay oh you knew what i was trying to do oh clever girl
all right i'm gonna put this here then you have to get rid
of your beans on your side soon can i keep them there
forever that's fucking right oh oh oh you made a fatal
mistake i've captured your beans That's fucking right.
Our beans are mine.
Oh, shit.
Wait, he captured mine.
That's okay.
It's okay.
Oh, that's right.
You messed up.
I'm laughing right now.
Give me a sec.
Oh, I'm not letting you capture this.
Oh, I saw your plan.
I can't oh fuck okay oh but you forgot about this damn right
captured your bean yet again okay all
right it's fine whatever I do it's fine you might capture
this bean but you're but I still won in the end get out of
here yeah get out of here i am the master at beaning i'm
being very careful now now that i
that's working right i'm the queen of beans i'm the queen of
beans
i oh the hell donkey i'm the bean queen
I'm not getting canceled right today.
Bean queen, bean queen, bean queen.
I'll challenge you.
Oh wait, he's fighting.
Oh, I'm P59.
I was like, which one am I?
wait which one's me wait am i playing am i p5 i'm p8 5 wait
my p no i'm not p wait i'm p8 5 okay i'm playing right now i
got confused i got confused who's playing and it was me all
along wait am i playing i'm p8 5 4 3 i'm i'm at the top I
couldn't tell.
I couldn't tell.
Okay, I figured out which penguin is me, guys.
I figured it out.
I was very confused.
I was so used to being at the top.
Or at the bottom here.
I was like, wait a minute, they're both V8-5.
Horrors.
What are you doing?
Counting?
You're trying to count?
Okay, I had to count too.
Me too.
Because so was I.
Can I capture my own?
Let's try and find out.
No, I can't.
Okay.
Go again.
My beans!
Damn right!
Give me your beans.
Oh shit, I forgot about those beans.
I forgot about those beans.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
I got you another bean.
Oh, I think I might have miscalculated.
Unless...
Give me a bean that someone else made an oopsie.
All right, you walked right into my trap.
That's right.
Bean Queen, Bean Queen has taken another penguin, has taken
another bean.
Bean, Queen, Bean Queen.
That's right.
All those days playing.
Oh my god.
That's right.
I came back.
And the bean queen does a counterplay.
No one expected.
Like my igloo.
All right.
What does your igloo look like?
Holy shit.
How much money does this girl spend?
What the fuck?
Oh, I got some more messages.
Come check in what's new in the book room.
All right.
Oh, this is where I was.
I was literally just here.
That's not even an igloo.
It's a fucking cabin.
All right, let's check my messages.
All right, message number two.
What's the play Mangala?
Congratulations.
Oh, thank you.
I know I'm a very good dancer.
try to tip the iceberg.
Wait, I need to know where to get the construction stuff.
Thank you.
You're funny.
Awesome outfit.
Thanks, I'm naked.
Dance off.
Happy New Year.
Cool name.
Dance off.
Let's hang out.
Awesome outfit.
Dance off.
Alright.
Let's see.
Wait, that penguin's from Brazil.
Where's that Brazilian penguin?
an accent clicked on you know what i'm gonna see your house
oh you don't like i'm gonna see check this guy's house
clover what is your house holy shit he has his own dance
floor that's right broke into this man's house let's go
guys party at this man's house guys party at this guy's
place like i saw hang out in this guy's area
the invasion of the yellow penguins i like how he has this
he has like like a random chinese new year thing over here
too just hang out at the top
Canadian women starts breaking into houses and starts
breaking it down Let's go Damn this guy has Wait which one's
a real puffle Oh they steal this puffle guys It'll be so
funny Let's steal this man's puffle Oh my god he has
basketball too He shoots He scores All right, let's go.
All right, let's play a real game.
It's time for a real game, guys.
Sled racing.
For how to play.
Oh, this is me.
Which one, which penguin is me, guys?
Which penguin?
Which one's me?
There's too many yellow penguins.
Hey.
I've lost track of the yellow Okay How the fuck he's taking
all the fucking ice slides No Oh it's so fast Oh my god From
downtown There you go It's okay second place is fine Second
place Wait all yellow penguins Okay we wait for the next run
guys Wait what's this?
Oh I don't have it We wait for the next one.
It's all yellow penguins.
Then we'll never know what okay all yellow penguins with the
p85 name Let's go in Oh, well Yellow, okay, well no Okay,
no, okay, oh yellow okay.
Okay, oh yellow peng okay.
All right.
Oh, yeah, okay.
That's a green penguin Okay,
oh yellow okay now that's okay All right, good enough.
Good enough.
Wait.
It's good enough, guys.
I just wanted to see if we could get lost in the sauce, you
know?
Just to see if we could get lost.
Be like, which one's the real?
Oh, my God.
That was unfortunate.
See, this is why we should have had all yellow penguins.
We got gang up on that blue penguin.
all right we have to gang up on this one penguin all right
all yellow penguins yes with the with the the non-approved
names the p85s p85s roll up p85 okay p85 oh my god wait we
just need one more where the fuck you had one job okay to be
fair i did it okay all right now we have a tobogganer We
have a guy on toboggan.
It was almost perfect.
He just had to pay to win.
Wow.
Okay.
Goddamn.
That's right.
That slate ain't doing shit no more, is it?
The P85 gang.
Oh, yeah.
You paid $300.
you last place all right p85 gang no sled no sled no items
final destination
pay to what pay to lose more like pay to l all right let's
go let's go p85's let's go let's go this is it we finally
did it we finally which was me which was me
Oh no!
I can't tell!
That's me!
Oh my god, I'm so lost!
Oh, perfect race doesn't exist!
Okay, okay, there's two of us now.
There's only two of us.
It's easier to tell.
It's now a little easier.
Oh shit, I thought I was the other guy.
Okay, there's two of us.
It's easier.
It's a little easier.
You're getting lost in the sauce.
There we go.
Second place again.
That's every P85 for themselves.
They're all in Tokyo.
She's just moving so fast.
That gold yellow one.
Go.
What's your house look like?
Holy shit.
She's rich.
Oh my.
It's a fucking ship.
Oh my god.
I wish this cost you.
I'm going to take.
I'm going to do it.
I'm going to jump.
All right.
Prepare a peculiar pancake.
Ask, oh, hey.
The St. Patrick's Day party is full swing.
Oh, it ends on March 19.
I'm pretty sure it's past March 19.
Oh, hey, you can submit your stories and stuff, too.
Dear Antarctic, what is a transformation and how do we get
one?
Are we going to send our own question?
If you are a yellow and gray fish, are there fish in other
colors, too?
The penguins coming in.
It would seem strange.
stranger fish only came in too and then featured igloos oh
my god somebody made the world cup oh that's cute oh it's
it's the kermit it's the kermit sign oh that's really cute
they recreated it
can I actually play this I can't even oh wait I can oh I can
actually play this what is this is that the iceberg all
right who is that what is that oh yeah yeah yeah sorry sorry
for not knowing what the fuck that was sorry it's rainbow
connection yeah oh wait you can have your fan art put on
here that's cute like i said that's a really it's as a
really active okay it's like who's that that Pokemon?
And he's like Snorriax.
And then the other guy's like, Pikachu.
Pikachu.
And it's always just Pikachu.
That's really cute.
That they you can have your fan art featured here.
That's so adorable.
Oh my god, someone made like a little club penguin skirt.
It's Pikachu.
Get a job?
Wait, it could be a pizza, man.
Oh my god, I can get a job.
Oh my god, Oh, I gave me a coffee barista.
I'll buy that.
I can't but have to buy...
I have to pay to have a minimum wage job.
Oh, now.
Puffin Digging.
Submit your content.
Oh, I can submit a riddle.
That's cute.
Alright.
Guys, I gotta...
Sorry, guys.
I can't play anymore.
I gotta go to my...
I gotta go to my nine-to-five.
Sorry, guys.
I can't hang out no more, guys.
My mom made me get her job.
I gotta go clock in.
I'll see you.
I gotta go to work.
Only fives.
Wait, can I...
Do I have the pizza?
Wait, how do they do the pizza flip?
I bought...
I paid for this.
How do they have the email?
I want to flip pizzas.
I...
Would you like a pizza?
I would do that.
I should role play as the waiter.
The minion city.
Oh, he left.
I think he got scared.
Support our swamp business.
Oh my god, there's a live fan.
There's
used D?
Oh, here you go.
Hello, ma'am.
I shall make a fresh pizza for you.
My Z key was not.
Don't worry, ma'am.
There's actual regular people.
There's so, so many yellow penguins here.
And it was like, pizza, pizza.
Pizza.
I'm so oversimplified.
I love my pizza makers.
But goodbye.
I'm, I'm sorry.
I'm gas smearers.
Dang.
I didn't even order pizza.
Why are you in a pizza parlor?
Maybe I should work.
It wasn't going.
Damn, damn horse.
Please, pizza.
Don't worry, each table gets its own little pizza, man.
Don't worry, I'll pizza for you.
Don't worry, pizza.
It's like, why are there so many yellow penguins?
I want spaghetti.
We don't serve spagget.
I'm out of late for your shit.
It's just pizza.
Let me speak.
I am the manager.
Oh, wait.
We have two managers.
We have two.
No.
we are the managers but which one do I complain to me that's
not sanitary this is awkward
we don't Don't...
Please, it's a...
Guys, please, this is a small business.
We don't serve spaghetti.
They just want to fucking serve pizza.
It's a fam, please.
They'll have to...
Please, this is all they have.
They spent all their money.
No, no!
No!
yes we have a pizza what do i do with this pizza oh it's you
wanted this pizza hello we made we made you your pizza guys
guys please please i'll play pizza try there we go this
place is a dump left because no oh oh my god wait i'm
actually making Pizza.
Okay, cheese pizza.
Alright, nice.
Alright, cheese pizza.
I'm pre-load- I'm pre-aiming.
I'm pre-firing right now.
Got my pizza.
Oh, with seaweed.
Alright, I can make that work.
Pre-firing.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Alright.
guys please we can't put them out of business they need to
put their kids through college
three four out of five
all right one two three four five i have a better we gotta
have their system instead of just putting toppings one by
one okay one two three four five squid pizza that does not
look like shit okay hot sauce cheese oh my god this this
entire piece is just drenched in hot sauce oh shit okay it's
all right i'll cover it up with pizza sauce no one will know
okay fish cheese all right one two oh okay i made it okay i
made it just in the corner just in the corner wait i think
it's getting a little faster Two, three, four.
Yeah, with the fish on one piece.
All on one piece.
There you go.
Saved.
One, two.
One, two, three, four, five.
Cheese!
I was like, why didn't it work?
What am I missing?
Oh, yeah, the cheese.
I don't know, I don't know.
Alright.
All the roleplayers hang out in the restaurant.
Alright, 5.
Get hot sauce.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Cheese!
I can't even get cheese.
I'm like, hmm, I wonder why this pizza isn't an appropriate.
Oh shit Wait it's getting faster Wait oh my god No It's
getting so fast
Okay There has to be an easier way to do this
Yeah at least I can put this This is not convenient at all I
gotta be able to grab a handful of that Oh my god Oh my god
it's over It's over, it's over, it's over I quit I quit I
don't want to work in this established.
Oh, I should buy a pet.
I'm going to buy a pet.
I made...
I worked so hard.
Alright, I worked so hard.
Clocking out.
Wait, how do I...
I don't want to be...
I don't want to work no more.
Please, I don't...
Please.
Let me take...
Oh, wait.
Okay, I just have to click here.
Alright.
Oh, pets.
Not just...
Oh, it has to be this other one.
Alright.
Adopt a poofler.
Oh, grab.
Adopt.
I should have enough.
Strong silent type.
Favorite toys.
Oh, my God.
Skateboard.
He's so cool.
Dirk.
What the fuck is Dirk?
Artistic.
Energetic.
i usually in the past you would you can only buy the blue
poofo because like the rest were just subscription based
which fucking was so stupid wait can you run away as long as
you care it will be waiting inside to get to your igloo your
poofo will run back to the wild all right guys we're not
getting a poofo i'm scared of him he's gonna run away uh
because i don't i i can't i'm i'm scared he's gonna run away
because then that means i'll have to play this game every
day and that's how it's like it's not like neo pets where
your your pets can just starve the poodle can actually run
away um um And then people are like, wow, Toki, you're a bad
owner.
That's how they get you.
I remember this game.
This game sucks.
What do you mean, escape?
This game fucking sucks.
All right.
Where do you get the construction stuff?
Oh, it has to be in the mines.
Where else would it be?
There's a recycling place now?
What the fuck?
You can recycle pizza?
What's going on?
How does this work?
Holy shit, my furniture is made out of pizza?
What do you mean my furniture is made out of pizza?
to teach it, Apex, and keep it in the basement.
Zekra, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, let's go to the mines.
I need to grab my outfit.
The children yearn for the mines.
Oh, for rescue.
How do we get the...
Oh, shit.
Oh, there it is.
You know, fine.
Digging in a new spot.
That's right.
I'm one of you guys now.
You work hard.
Face me.
I am the elephant.
Now the bean.
But you're an elephant.
I am the elephant of Club Penguin.
someone acknowledge him please he's the elephant of club
penguin i don't dress him
reminding my other nine to five job i'm like that that
part-time worker um in gunball And five to six, I do this,
and then I do that.
How's the wave?
What not per log?
What?
Who is he talking to?
Would anyone reply back?
How many animals are in this island, bro?
You have two left.
What do penguins sing on a birthday?
degenerated.
Wait, somebody's digging!
That's not jackhammering!
Oh my god.
The shark and the elephant are fighting.
Are the shark
and penguin friends?
Oh, and not in Elephant, friends.
Oh my god, they're dancing.
Pizza shark and elephant.
Oh my god.
And car.
Don't forget car.
Wait, that's a car.
Wait, that's a penguin.
Holy, that's just a car.
What the fuck?
It's just a fucking car.
I thought it was part of the scenery.
I thought it was just somebody left their toy car.
He's naturally joking.
What does your house look like?
Oh, shit.
Well, I'm caught on cameras too late now.
Grandfather.
Seems like, uh, I mean, it's pretty cool.
cool it's pretty it's a pretty nice pad you know i would
thought it'd be better like you know for a car to live in
you know i would i i mean it's pretty cozy i just thought
you know he would live in a more car-like environment
you mean where does he sleep yeah you haven't seen the
garage is there a garage guys i don't think there's a garage
here guys oh my god i can't leave this door is just okay i
was gonna say where the fuck is the door the forest oh yes
the forest
oh my god we guys they're on a date guys we gotta leave
What is he saying?
Does anyone know language he's saying?
Ayuda.
He's just...
I ruined their e-day.
Help!
He's saying help in Spanish.
Yes, I'm scared.
I gotta leave.
Oh my god, Chow Bunga, bro.
Oh my god, you're ruining their day.
They were in a nice forest just secluded from the rest of
the world.
From the rest of the world.
And then we just, just a horde of yellow penguins just came
up.
The Yellow Penguin Invasion
We're just here We're here to expand the beach We're just
here to expand the beach, guys Oh, is this a pajama party?
Wait, oh my god Wait, I love pajama party
let me also be yellow
don't worry i'm enjoying wait it's my off day now let me
take up my hat off we're just chilling telling campfire
story anyone have a campfire story
I just told my story
It's about a red car Who's famous How famous is the red car?
He says Kachau
Wait, I want to talk to P7 P7 Is your Wait, my number keys
don't work
that's a problem how cool is your house pink penguin with a
scarf
wait is he pink oh wait that's a green sorry I mean green I
mean a green penguin with a scarf
you're so green
I just want to know how cool her house is I okay I keep
thinking
She's ignoring me I have another store That's it I'm going
oh wait She closed her house I can't invade her house It's
sad Holy shit where am I I actually don't know where i am
but it's time it's time to go to my other nine to five tip
the iceberg everybody we gotta tip the iceberg we gotta tip
it where am i
oh i have to be on this side oh i found myself i found
myself there i am go we gotta tip it over here to the left
guys we have to tip it there's the entire point we won't
leave until we tip that iceberg we gotta do it all right
let's see what what message is penguin band rocks let's hang
out check out my igloo whose igloo is this okay i can't
fucking see it happy new year your puffins are cool i don't
have one greetings you have the making oh i do i have a
secret a do wants to play mangada let's try and tip the
iceberg you're funny oh actually i think i read all of the
others before don't worry we're tipping it guys welcome to
the next wait wait hour you mean oh my god it's it's he man
he's calling guys we can do this we can tip our ice the
iceberg yeah stream won't end till we tip the iceberg that
was the whole point of this stream he has the power guys
guys this is the server where the iceberg tips guys i can't
tell look like it's tipping guys i'm a little worried it
doesn't look like it's tipping at the moment it yeah
apparently official disney uh comics joked about tipping the
iceberg not tipping oh it tips 50 guys we need more people
guys we need more people to tip the iceberg guys grab
everyone you know
grab everyone you know
everyone we have a mission mega thank you with a super chat
thank you thank you watch out for c bears we have to keep
drilling all right who's doing that guys please think about
global warming you're increasing the ozone layer
do we need no no not everyone has to be on one side
i don't think so i'm pretty sure uh so so here what do you
mean that's not what that means one dumb thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you wait i have an idea guys i
haven't it will come back here we'll come back here guys i
don't i still want to guys i just realized i still want to
stuff before we come back yet.
But I haven't not...
Oh, the dock!
Hey.
Al.
Oh, he left.
You can't run away from me.
Where are you going?
Oh, I think that's actually a kid.
I should leave.
I think...
I should not I cannot I should not harass children Alright
That's why I love this game
I'm not Am I supposed to grab anything Oh I am Oh shit I'm
not Wait actually Let me read the rules I need to read the
rules for this game Leave the kid alone Alright Okay that's
all the rules Okay Just jump Wee.
Okay, but look at this.
Oh, I'm going to have some Tony Hawk shit right now.
Look at me do some sick-ass trick.
Okay, the more stuff you jump over it, the more points you
get.
Look at this sick-ass trick.
Oh, my God.
Double the air tab.
Look at that air tab.
Cannot be jumped.
Okay, we can't jump the boys.
I can still jump the iceberg.
Oh, bump.
Oh my, this game is so easy.
They should have this in the Winter Olympics.
You know, I just found out that there's a professional sport
for, like, what is it called?
The cornhole?
Because of the guy that marries someone.
I was like, the, what was it?
that fucking murdered a guy and that's how I found out
there's a professional because he's apparently a
professional cornhole player and yeah and then people like
how the fuck did he when he shoot a gun when he has no hat
when he has no arms or legs and then the guy literally um
yeah no there was like a fucking there was a guy that like
was I don't know if he was like a double amputed or, uh, or,
like, a quad amputed, because, like, he basically has no
arms.
And then, and then people are, like, always swim with a
buddy.
Wait, what does that even mean?
Oh, I can clap, I can jump.
And then, like, there's someone's, like, he's, like, like
this.
And then it was, like, a fucking video of him fucking
shooting a gun with no hands.
It was crazy.
It was actually crazy to see.
Um, oh yeah, he got no legs.
He got no legs and arms, and, like, he can shoot a rifle and
a pistol.
Like, there's clips of him shooting a rifle and and stuff
and then I was just like Jesus Christ I was just like how
the fuck is he the murder suspect like yeah yeah yeah and
because we were so fucking confused anyway he's also a
professional cornhole player and that's how I found out that
that's a real sport oh boy I said one more let bro zip
whoops but that's how i found out we must help fish jesus
this is a grim reaper oh my god they're fishing we all want
to fish what are these guys did you guys catch any did you
guys catch anything good
are they at AFK or do you think they'll actually play
how does he play cornhole with no arms
it's like professional tag well i'm not i'm not trying to
say cornhole is like professional tag but like i'm just
crazy i just thought it was fucking funny that there's like
an actual professional sport with cornhole i have this
interview wait what what did she say Aww, he's talking about
work.
That's cute.
They're actually...
Oh, like my igloo.
Alright, how sick is your igloo?
Why did it take me here?
Oh, how sick is your igloo?
Holy!
We are not the same.
I am clearly on the other spectrum.
I am... I'm poor, apparently.
This is how I find out I'm poor.
this is how I find out I'm poor I've entered this igloo
before I guess I just forgot it just still shocks me every
time I see it it oh this guy no this is how I find out I'm
poor I'm
this this is how I find out that I I'm at the bottom of the
of the chat system i guarantee the upper class exists in
club penguin oh my god they even have a fucking a garden
statue in their own home
all right playing penguin is a 2008 and i didn't know it
crystal thank you the super chat thank you thank you come to
my japanese igloo all right all right spike whoa okay that's
cute it's like neopets where they also like customize their
uh their neopets with like fashion okay that's sick too
that's cute i must have taken a lot of coins to make this oh
my god he has his own swing all right let's see Oh, yeah, I
want to go to the ski village.
It's, wait, what's this?
If you're new, you like, find, take a tour.
Tourist will get to look at your tour guide near.
Is your tour guide holding tours here?
Sign, you can join the guide's group.
Follow the guide on a tour around once the tour is over.
If you'd like to become a tour guide, that's cool.
Are there any, oh, she's gone.
Talk to tour, but I want, how can I get the tour?
Just find a penguin wearing hat.
are thank you so much okay must be at least 45 days old wait
i want to take the tour where the tour wow oh my god such a
sick view let's do a puzzle i should use the bathroom first
all right let's hang out all right all right you guys you
guys take in the view i'm gonna go right back oh my god
where's the band play some music where are my band goons my
band wins play some music guys i'll be right back
all right why are there non-yellow penguins here
if you want to join the yellow penguin crew the least you
can do is be yellow
p859122 grenard of 603 Green Penguin discrimination
Affiliate, Lil Cyclone, GSS, John, Papa, Smurf, Smug,
Neppers, Nexy, Bite, WB, Solid, Allen, Medi, thank you for
the super chat, thank you, thank you.
That was the entry-level requirement to join the crew.
You gotta be yellow.
out out of the club
you heard her folks that's right there's a yellow that's
right look at that see is that easy hey you where aren't you
yellow hey you don't make me wait i can't i'll ignore you
that's right the moment i ignore you you get snapped out of
existence so you better turn Gotta buy yellow.
That's right.
I only see yellow penguins in there.
No, that's right.
That's right, Smurf.
Where's your...
Why aren't you yellow?
Huh?
That's right.
Smurf.
Why are you not yellow?
This is the yellow club.
I'm going...
That's right.
There was an ignore button.
P84.
8572.
Where's your yellow?
Holly.
Hi, can I get a tour?
Wait, I don't think this guy is part of the crew.
I think this guy's actually new.
He's just trying to get a tour guide.
I'm new to why am i getting oh no guys that's actually a
child he's just been trying he's just been trying to find a
door guide he can't turn yellow he's actually new
oh no yeah get out of here Every one day people are just
trying to find a tour guide.
I invaded.
I just invaded the fucking the fucking tourist the tour
agency
I'm still trying to find a tour guide Where is the tour
guide?
All right.
We need a bouncer to make sure everybody's yellow Any
non-yellow.
All right.
P85.
I see you're not yellow turn yellow right this instance or
i'm gonna click that ignore button all right better be oh
live on camera all right oh my god i don't know which one's
part of my crew and which one wait where's the tour guide
where is it what's this we're trying We are trying to find a
tour guide.
Do you know any?
Oh, she left.
I don't know who's part of my group and who's not anymore.
Okay.
All right.
Anyway.
Let's play Connect 4.
Oh, my God.
That's a Christmas tree.
actually we're going to the attic this poor lady is just
trying to chill this is our this is our club now it's our
club all right where's a bouncer we need a bouncer wait
you're not yellow i can tell you're not yellow you're just a
tree that's right that's what i could tell all right we need
a bouncer right here to make sure everybody's yellow all
right we gotta have a bouncer here A bouncer penguin.
This is our club.
No other color.
Oh, no other color penguins allowed.
Tour here.
That's a tour.
Okay, I'll get a tour later.
But like, we need a bouncer here to make sure everybody,
you're not yellow.
Why are you not?
I don't even know.
This is the yellow club.
Well, I'll play a connect for it with you.
Alright.
Which one's me?
Alright, let's go.
Connect for
Go It's your turn How am I supposed to play If he doesn't If
he doesn't do it Make a turn
Guys I think he's not I think it's broken Why is everyone
How is he What the fuck What is he doing here There was no
one in this attic when I came in.
We just fucking adopted this fucking random guy.
No, wait.
He's actually yellow underneath.
He's just wearing a horse costume.
It's Bojack.
Wait, it's Bojack Horseman.
Wait, it's actually Bojack Horseman.
Okay, now...
Alright, I'm ready.
Is that me?
Oh, he's quit the game.
Wait, I haven't.
Oh my god, I can't even click it.
There's too many penguins.
Okay.
Is that me?
I've always lost track which...
There's too many P85s.
I've always lost track of which one it is.
Someone, please!
I just want to play Connect 4!
Please!
make a turn let me play i'll never be able to play connect 4
i'll never be able to play all right i'm at the top i'm red
all right there you go there you go now i can do a turn
all right they'll never expect this strategy
Oh, what's going on in this brain right now?
You'll never know.
Ha!
Connect 4!
Get out of here!
I'm a professional!
That's right.
Give me the next one!
Bam!
BAM
BAM Oh You think you're pretty clever But are you more
clever than this?
BAM I saw through you BAM That's fucking right
I see right through your lies BAM
What am I doing?
Give me a sec.
I need to see what I'm trying to do.
What am I trying to do?
I got lost.
I will be honest.
I got lost in the sauce.
I got a little two.
A little two into that.
I forgot what I was trying to do.
Don't worry.
We have a system here.
A night four!
That's right.
Get out of here.
Another one.
That's fucking right.
I got lost at one point, but I made it back.
I made it back home.
It's all about the journey.
And the end.
I'm cooking something right now.
I'm cooking.
Bada-dum, bada-dum, bada-dum.
Bada-dum, bada-dum.
What the fuck is he trying to cook right now?
Get out of here.
I don't know what I'm trying to do anymore.
I will be honest with you guys.
I also got lost.
I'm just putting circles down.
Yeah,
where are you going to do, huh?
Where are you going to place yours?
Okay.
I fucked up.
But we'll never know who won that match.
We'll never know.
That's right.
This guy will not...
Oh, he quit.
We'll never know.
We'll never know who won.
I said I think I fucked up.
that I did fuck up.
We never know.
It could have been anyone.
Oh my god, let's play hockey.
Oh my god, hey.
Let's watch a hockey game together.
Sir?
Alright.
Let's play hockey.
Play hockey for me, guys.
Go!
Oh!
Go to my igloo for party stamp, please.
Go to my igloo.
Alright, let's see.
How cool is your igloo?
Holy shit!
This is a party party.
Oh my god.
Alright, let's check this guy.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, this is a nice place.
thousand likes.
It's actually quite beautiful.
That is not an igloo.
Whoever's igloo this is, they literally change the ecosystem
of the Arctic's It's a little bit of paradise.
It sure is.
Oh my god.
This water, I bet, is purified, too.
It's super filtered.
This is what the global warming has hit this igloo.
It is so cute, though.
This place is...
Oh, my God.
Wait, an astronaut came back.
Came back from space to be here.
Oh, it's snow for it!
Cheetah, girl.
What's your igloo look like?
Holy shit.
Okay, this guy's a cat, girl.
This guy's a crazy cat, lady.
Bit too many puffins, what might I add?
Bit too many.
It's time.
This is what we train for.
Wait, where am I?
Wait, give me a sec.
I've lost track of where I am.
I think there's too many yellow penguins.
I can't figure out which one's me anymore.
Oh my god, you're everywhere.
Who is everywhere?
I just logged it.
Why are you there?
Wait, I hope you didn't say anything.
I actually want to go to the stadium.
I...
Oh, he left.
He got too overstimulated.
With the
yellow...
He got overstimulated.
There's too many yellow penguins.
War never changed.
I haven't not been to.
Let's see.
I think I went everywhere here.
What's on the notice board?
Funny party.
Location.
March.
Oh, we missed that.
Oh, that's cute.
What?
Oh, you can host your own community events.
Round table discussion at my igloo.
What are you discussing?
is this an intervention
it was like you and all yell what are we discussing about
where's the guy it was supposed to be a fucking discussion
where is my discussion where is turn yellow what is this
who's this guy
it's funny he's just like he's like now all of you turn
yellow well not even me yet I didn't ask for the yellow part
this time
oh my god he's demanding now oh he left he left because
we're not He fucking got mad.
He got so mad that we were not all yellow.
See guys, I told you guys we should all be yellow.
I told you guys now you made him leave.
Now you made him leave.
He got mad that we're not all yellow.
It ruined the vibe.
It ruined the...
Wait, what?
At the dojo.
What's going on at the dojo?
nothing's going on here try to earn your belts once you have
earned challenge if you win I don't get it card jitsu
practice card jitsu is that sensei good day grasshopper to
begin training your first required these cards just like a
real I never played card jitsu to increase your rank you
must compete in matches with hard work
are you ready now yes please you know what let's play the
game i'll learn like i'll learn as we go i'll learn live i
can figure it out let's i can figure out trial and error you
know trial and error
which one's me okay all right this Wait, I won Wait, I I won
Nice, get out of here Okay Five Ten Wait, I, lower cards
have more value Lower cards have more value, I remember Okay
Um Seven Yes!
Oh, what?
Is it still lower cards?
Oh, is it because... Oh, it's rock, paper, scissors.
It's rock, paper, scissors.
Okay.
Okay, here.
That should win.
Yes!
All right.
Element, okay.
no way it has to be fire again oh you're stream sniping you
fucker you're stream sniping you fucker you're you waited i
can wait too
you cheater
P859122 Nice Get out of here When do I win?
Like, when do I win?
That's why I wait.
Oh, fuck again?
When they die, we have health points?
There's no way to have another one.
Are you...
Fuck, yes!
Yes, fire wins!
Fire beats ice!
Yay!
I win!
That's fucking right.
I'm ready.
I'm ready to play Karjitsu.
Okay.
So I need water, water, water.
Or water, fire, ice.
Or water.
God damn it.
It's like I'm fighting myself.
Alright, fuck.
Okay.
Pretend you didn't see that.
Guys, cover your screen.
Look away.
I cover it.
Like, you don't know.
You don't
you don't see it.
You don't see it.
I'm waiting.
I can wait, too.
Come on.
No!
My good card!
Come on.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god.
He's playing mind games with me right now.
There's no way.
Oh, thank god, buy one.
Buy one.
There's no way.
Are you serious?
Okay.
That's okay, it's all right.
I gotta put this on.
yes okay all right this is five this is five
no I forgot the lower value I forgot about the lower value
okay this guy this guy is a regular penguin he can't be
stream sniping he's actually just chill in here.
He's literally just hanging out.
There's no way.
Nice.
No!
He had the reversal.
I forgot he had a reversal.
Let's do another ice.
There's no way it's a fire.
Nice.
What does purple belt mean?
Like, what tier is it?
God damn it.
What tier is purple belt?
It's like diamond ring.
He's a veteran.
He's been chilling here for a while.
Ha ha ha ha.
Get out of here.
Okay, maybe he's trying to force.
God, fuck.
Okay.
He was trying to force it.
it i might have to go oh my god he's reading my mind i'm not
thinking right now he knows he knows i'm not thinking right
now i'm just playing the game
he knows
no i was i wanted to put to i was going to
now 12 oh wait wait yes i win i think i win i think yes get
out of here get out of here that's fucking right get the out
of here diamond ring ha ha fucking baby shit maybe you don't
deserve to be in that elo that guy grinded to get time that
guy just played so many games i Got diamond ring.
That's fucking right.
It's so it's like Apex where you just play to play for a
rank.
What's that word called?
Get out of it.
Oh my god, he bought those cards.
He bought that 12 card.
Didn't matter.
Didn't fucking matter.
Pay to win.
Oh,
I can have a hoodie?
What kind of outfit is there?
What can I have?
Oh, my God, that's cute.
Are there any yellow outfits?
I can be fully yellow.
I can be, I have a scarf in my yellow outfit.
What if it's just all yellow?
Oh, my God, you can be a snail.
Wait.
Wait, I must have this.
Oh, that's cool.
You can, like, put flags on it, too.
Yeah, he grinded.
Do I, am I still yellow?
Can you tell if I'm yellow or not?
All right, everyone.
We're all in a new, new rule.
We all have to be snails now.
we are we are rebranding we're rebranding everyone the
yellow club is now the snail club we're rebranding we're
restructuring now it's from dragons the snails you guys like
my new look I'm too poor It's time to grind some beans It's
time to grind You're kicked out If you're not a snail Your
membership will be revoked If you're not a snail A snail
Will I ever get a tour guide
You think people Still shouldn't up there Oh hey there's a
guy here oh wait there's several guys here it's so comfy up
here i like how you can see everything and it's cute i don't
want to play jigsaw jam totally i don't want to play jigsaw
jam anymore i snails only oh yeah wait i did have a tour
guide all right let's go back to ski village for the tour.
Alright.
Let's wait for the tour guide.
We're waiting for the tour.
Let's chill until the tour guide.
Oh shit tour guide!
Light blue!
Light blue.
I like a tour please.
Here you go.
Tour please.
Please.
Take us on a tour.
I just got my license.
Where should we go?
We are new in town.
Alright.
I have.
Alright, let's follow him.
He's...
Only the tour guide can be yellow!
So we can find him.
We can find him in the fucking sea of snails.
This is the ski village.
Is it famous?
We can go fish here.
That's so cool.
And quit cool sports stuff.
Wow.
What's the secret?
Secret agent stuff.
Where's secret?
I don't want secret agent stuff.
Press on M twice into winner Oh
Help keep this That just tells me Alright let's go do that
Press the M twice Where's the M?
It just tells me to keep the place safe Where?
This tour guide sucks
I don't think this tour guide is getting a five star from
me, guys.
The other M?
Where's the other M?
Oh, wait.
We have another tour guide.
Oh, check mail?
It says happy birthday.
Click M to apply.
Aloha.
Happy New Year.
Have another M?
Oh.
I get a spot phone Pick that you think In charge Being a Not
being my buddy What will you do?
Saw a penguin yell at Throw snowballs at them My personal
equipment should be reported Saying boy or girl
okay pick one reasons i want a spy phone pick another reason
why you want to be a secret agent i mean oh i want to hang
out thank you you're if you're accepted you'll be prompted
to accept if not please try again lid you think i got it you
think i got i think i got past the test guys okay all right
honest being mooted i mean i think i have i think i got
rejected guys
okay there we go spy phone has been added to your instant
rejection guys i'm a spy now i'm new God, guys, I did it.
I became a spy.
I don't even just tour.
I'm going to give that tour guide one star.
I'm going to go to teleport, visit HQ.
Who's here?
Welcome.
Oh my God, how did they know I was going to come here?
Oh my God, it's like they're spies or something.
It's like, it's like they're spies.
I'm letting me Mission 1.
Oh my god, this is an actual mission.
Oh my god, it's like an actual, holy shit, wait, I'm too
stupid right now to do this.
I'm too tired right now to do this at the moment.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, guys.
I don't think my brain can do this at the moment.
Good luck.
I just want to be a snail.
I just want to be a snail, I guess.
I'll come back later.
I just want to be a snail right now.
Who knew being a secret agent was really hard.
Report any players that are using Keep Your Dendly and the
idea of other secret agents.
Oh my god, no whistleblowers.
and have the best experience reasons to report rude or mean
they're hidden by us click to make new items sure oh wait
that's cool you can get a viking helmet secret missions but
why aren't secret agents a secret everyone's the couple
mentions usually nope your secret is safe because the
penguin has will never mention specific names oh my god i
can have sun go wait i'm buying that special dances weird
and you'll put coffee and oh oh my god forgot about the
hawaiian penguins secret code wait let me put on my
sunglasses god i'm so cool now
i'm so fucking cool
guys i think there's a secret agent Among Us.
Sounds kind of sus.
Who could it be?
I don't know.
It could be any one of us.
It could be you.
It could even be.
Have I been everywhere?
This has been fun, though.
Let's go.
been to the movie theater wait what the fuck a space
adventure all right quick wait there's costumes oh that's
cool you
can be like an app you're gonna be a an alien what's the
script now landing on that planet all right put on a show
Wait, can I be up here?
Oh, I can.
I'm not.
Gnorp.
But entertain me, my penguins.
My snails.
I'm definitely a snail, guys.
I'm totally a snail.
Wait, I want to be up here.
That's the VIP section.
Get out of my way.
Wait, how did he get up there?
Oh.
Alright.
Now I'm VIP too.
So yeah, I'm VIP too.
There we go.
I am a chicken nugget.
What the fuck?
Wow.
This plot goes crazy.
This plot goes fucking crazy.
This script is a mess.
I think this play might suck, guys.
I think this play...
It might be...
Fucking terrible.
I don't know.
Alright.
Let's.
You guys know what to do.
It's time.
Alright.
Let me hide this real quick.
The final.
The finale.
Before we end this.
We gotta do one more thing.
In Cloud Penguin.
One last thing.
Let me.
How do I do this?
do this give me a sec i'm trying to remember uh wait i can
take a wait uh oh i could take a picture
sick that's pretty sick that's pretty sick i'm trying to
figure out something real quick
Oh, yeah, I know.
All right.
All right, everyone.
Head to Zipline.
I'm on the Zipline server.
You know what that means.
Sam, I'm in the Zipline server, guys.
Zipline server.
time to go away what oh do i have to be fully just that oh
no i gotta take off the snail outfit yeah take off the snail
outfit guys we gotta help the crew we gotta help
we gotta help the crew to tip the ice iceberg no it's just
all yellow penguins now tip the iceberg on
my side dragons on my side keep drilling I swear to you I'm
gonna look at this I swear to God the fucking if this does
not have it all right tip the iceberg Club penguin journey I
swear to God If this They don't have it Iceberg It's not No
they can't do this to me It's not possible to tip the
iceberg That's quitter's talk That's quitter
The iceberg Okay 2026 Alright who is it Who is it?
me i could turn off sound effects guys
i could turn off sound effects don't believe the lies toky
the only time it was possible during the club penguin 20th
anniversary that's that's a lie who wrote this wiki it ended
on october oh my god it was just three days span from
october 20th until october October 20th.
That's a lie.
There's no way.
It's gonna tip, guys.
It's gonna tip any moment now.
Why is there an octopus?
Who's this...
Any minute now.
They say it tips every hour, guys.
It's almost that hour.
What about the 21st anniversary, huh?
No one ever thinks about the 21st anniversary.
Don't worry.
It's gonna tip at 7.33, guys.
At 7.33, it's gonna happen.
It's gonna happen, guys.
It's gonna...
We're dark blue.
How dare you suggest a thing to the yellow club?
This is a yellow penguins club.
We've rebranded again.
We're going back to our origins to what to what our main
message was to be a yellow penguin we've rebranded and
restructured again but this time we're yellow we're back
we're back to where we started
yes absolutely you're not a yellow penguin Guys, I don't
think it's gonna tip, guys.
Guys, I don't think it's, I think.
Guys, I have a feeling it might not tip, guys.
Anytime.
Any second now.
He's right.
At 735, it's gonna tip.
It's like that, it's like that short, that YouTube, those
YouTube streams, where they're like, I'm gonna push the
button, guys.
I'm gonna push the T-threat.
and it's gonna bite me oh my god make sure you're subscribed
right now guys make sure you're subscribed so i can finally
press the t press the button and it's gonna hurt so much my
hands are shaking right now oh i'm gonna do it any minute
now oh oh make sure to like the like the stream everybody
make sure like streams and then when i finally do it when i
oh my god when the timer hits it hits zero i'm gonna do it
guys i'm gonna hit that hit that like button and i'm gonna
gonna tip the iceberg's gonna tip guys make sure to like and
subscribe the video and then and then the iceberg is gonna
tip in 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 oh my god my hands are shaking oh
my god my hands my hands are shaking right now oh make sure
to make sure to subscribe so you don't miss out when the
iceberg is tipping i'm gonna do it i'm gonna tip it's gonna
tip you're off because i had watch five it like showed up in
my youtube shorts like i mean i've seen them around but it
showed on my youtube shorts yesterday and i actually watched
five minutes of that just to be like i just was like i was
like what does he say to keep going like i was curious i was
so curious like how is he gonna say how does he keep i was
like truly after the timer goes zero it's gonna press it but
he's kept going.
It's just like, he just kept going and going and going.
I was like, that's a skill.
That's a fucking skill right there.
Um, guys, guys, I can feel it tipping.
Oh, oh my God, I'm shaking right now.
I can feel it, guys.
I can, it's gonna, I'm gonna do it.
I'm just gonna tip.
It's gonna tip everybody.
Oh my God.
and it's pre-recorded too they just run a pre-work because
it's so funny um i've seen like um i've seen like i think
i've seen it when it first started and the original ones
obviously they're not perfected to the port to the what they
are now they are not perfected to the to the like the scam
basically they're just trying to get a bunch of subscribers
on the account and then they sell the account later they
sell the youtube account later um it's like the ones where
they're like oh don't don't like don't subscribe like those
like ones where they every time you it's like the minecraft
ones where every time you subscribe like they're trying to
do a build and then you subscribe and it destroys the build
and they're like stop subscribing stop subscribing you're
ruining my build i want to end stream but now they're doing
this because it i guess it's more engagement fading because
you're like oh my god is he gonna press it or not uh but
when it first started if you go to their live streams and go
all the way to the beginning like you can see the guy pull
up he's just sitting on his chair and he pulls up the video
and then plays it you can literally see him fucking put the
video on his stream and then you see like him pressing play
and everything it's so fucking stupid and so he never
presses the button never presses the button to fucking have
the croc the crocodile bite his head and they never press it
it's like they're just edging don't worry guys it's gonna
tip it's gonna tip any it's gonna tip right now guys don't
worry you're gonna miss out oh my god oh my god you guys
ready are you guys ready for it to tip oh my god it's gonna
do it it's gonna do it in any second now any second don't
miss out don't
it's so fucking stupid it's so dumb i wasted five minutes of
my life yesterday watching that i'm so excited when are you
gonna sell it all right guys guys i think we got engagement
baited guys i don't think it's gonna tip let's go back to
our hangout guys where it all began actually wait is there
anybody at the pizza shop this is a more empty server oh my
god there's no one at guys guys alright guys it's time we're
rebranding again we're rebranding again guys we're
rebranding put on the costume we're going we're going back
to the snails we're going back to snails.
I think this is our true form to what we truly are.
Free pizza pie.
And we're going back.
Why are you green?
I know you were trying to join the change, right?
You either are yellow or a snail, one or the other.
Don't make me ignore you.
I will ignore everyone until they're out of yellow, snail,
or both.
Don't make me do it.
I'm sorry, Doki.
I feel the pizza place is gonna tip, guys.
The pizza place is gonna tip, everyone.
I'm in the stream, just up clubbing.
Let's just say my pink well.
Don't make me do it.
It's right here in 10 seconds.
10, 9, 8, 7.
Make sure to like and subscribe.
guys make sure to like and subscribe and i'm gonna ignore
him right after guys when the timer hits zero i'm gonna go
ignore him everybody make sure you comment and subscribe
below
stop it cries it's too late i shall now Thanos you say
goodbye to p702345
he's gone he's just he's gone he's disappeared
all right i'm checking everybody i'm checking everybody to
make sure they're a snail or yellow you that you that us
that's right good oh my god there's a doctor in the house
There we go.
That's right.
I made an exact...
What the fuck?
Wait, you're...
I guess...
It has to be a purple snail.
Don't make me do it.
Don't make me do it, Ben.
That's right.
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, there you go.
That's right.
Bro, went full snail.
Nice.
All them all the music goons goons go perform on stage.
That man went full snail.
Dance for me on the stage.
I like a pizza please
That's right we took over the From where I first started
Where I began as a humble Waiter role player
That's where I got started Pizza That's the Pizza.
What the fuck?
I love pizza.
Pizza time.
Hello.
I was like, how was there a pizza there earlier?
And then I served it to someone.
That's crazy.
I don't know how that.
Oh wait, is it this?
What's this?
Would you like to play pizza oven?
What's this game?
I don't remember this game.
He wants pizza.
Oh.
It's just like.
I get it.
This game.
Wait.
Who took my seat?
Hello.
What?
Oh my god.
It's a double ganger.
I'm like.
Why are there so many snails?
Wait.
I'll go up to him.
Oh, he left.
He was doing his dailies, guys.
He was doing his dailies to get money.
To get the coins.
There is a green one.
Pizza time.
Simon says it's just...
Oh my god, which is the real dokey?
Who could it be?
Which is the real one?
It could be any one of us.
But um...
Everyone!
Dance!
Everyone.
Or make pizza!
That's right.
We're all dancing.
Oh my god, we're having it.
Look at this.
What a way to end it.
What a beautiful family.
the two only options dancing or pizza well I'm not gonna
stop him from doing his job
this is a small business guys they need to get paid they
have a family they actually have a family to provide for
okay Roman bonding this is a this is a happy family here
we're all happy in this club right You love it here Everyone
Give me hearts To prove To show everyone You love it here
That's right See guys they all love it here Look at that
Yeah see Look at that guys It's all consensual Nobody's here
against their way will nobody's here against the world yeah
against their will yes look at all these hearts it's so
wholesome really is that was fun though it was really fun to
revisit club penguin i haven't been on here for i didn't get
bad i said every my i didn't get bad the moderations didn't
The automated moderation didn't get me.
Thank God.
See you guys, we're so awesome.
And I had a great time revisiting Club Penguin and just
exploring the world with everybody again.
It was very fun.
It's nice to see how active the community is even without,
you know, even with us like walking around the yellow
penguin slash snail invasion.
like how active the community was and, you know, what the
dev team, what the fans have been trying to do to keep this
game alive and everything.
One game I really want to try is Toontown.
I've never played Toontown before.
I never grew up with...
I didn't... I mean, when I was on the Disney website, I
would just play the sandwich game.
I wouldn't play, like, Toontown or anything.
But that's one... I know that one also has a very active
community itself where
and um and everything so that's something i also wanted to
try out in the future yeah it's nice to see like how much
you're trying to do to make sure like uh the community stays
alive and to like make it uh very kid friendly very like a
very safe place for kids as well um so like uh which we
don't have a lot in the new generation of online gaming so
had a great time have a great time and I hope you're feeling
better.
I'm glad I'm here to help you cheer you up.
Anyway, guys, I'm going to call it here.
We had a long week of long streams this week.
So I hope you guys, all my dragoons are full with all the
dokyum I provided this week after being on vacation for a
while.
Thank you guys for hanging out with me today.
Next week, I don't really have anything much confirmed next
week other than two Halo streams because...
um because we want to make sure to be we're able to i'll
room i want to make sure i remember the controls every time
i play so it's at one halo stream a week we're gonna be
doing two halo streams next week so that's the only thing
i've confirmed for next week i have nothing oh and a member
stream because i overslept the last member stream um so
we're gonna have the icon drawing your profile picture um
poorly icon commissions member stream for next week as well
at 12 30.
uh anyways nope we're on heroic on heroic guys not on
legendary never again i know i said can be bribed to do
things but like i have to be bribed a lot now if i'm gonna
do legendary i'm not gonna get scammed again hey guys i'm
gonna try and stay up today because my sleep schedule is i
don't melatonin but i've never had melatonin before so i'm
like a little worried i don't want i'm like i'm really
worried of trying melatonin just because i never tried it
before but like uh some of my friends are like you should
try melatonin you're having trouble sleeping because i never
had trouble sleeping before it was just like today where i
had it was just like this week i think it's like the
combination of jet lag and all this stuff i all the stress
and stuff um yes you can buy you can buy my dignity but then
i realized that my dignity was deserved better
hey guys as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get
up and move around to get that blood flowing if you stay up
for me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys
next time everybody bye guys bye